to commemorate the first day of pride
month the new york times is admitting
that conservatives are totally right
about transgenderism in a profile of
will thomas who is the hulking male
swimmer that beat all the girls at the
ncaa championship the times included a
section titled the debate over the
science
but as the times acknowledged there is
not much debate
beginning in the womb the times admits
men are bathed in testosterone and
puberty accelerates that men on average
have broader shoulders bigger hands and
longer torsos and greater lung capacity
at heart capacity muscles are denser the
times even quotes a sports physiologist
who applies these scientific facts to
will thomas quote thomas is the
manifestation of the scientific evidence
dr ross tucker explains to the times the
reduction in testosterone did not remove
her
biological advantage
lots of conservatives are going to be
happy that the times is finally
acknowledging that boys and girls are
different they're going to say that this
may finally be the beginning of the end
for transgender ideology
and i hate to burst their bubble
but i think the opposite is true
i think this is the beginning of an even
more radical stage of the sexual
revolution
in the past transgender activists have
tried to argue that men who think
they're women really are women and it
was never very convincing but they were
trying at least
to make sense of transgenderism
increasingly it seems they've given up
on that
now they're not interested in making
sense of their sexual ideology at all
they're just interested in enforcing it
no more logic no more arguments no more
sense
just the sheer tyranny of will
this is not the beginning of the end of
transgenderism i'm sorry to tell you i
wish that it were conservatives have
been waiting for years now they say
transgenderism that's it that's going to
be finally the the damn breaking with
all this crazy leftism they're not going
to be able to hold it together anymore
people are going to flee i'm not sure
that's true not sure that's true at all
frankly at least in the old days when
they would say look the the hulking
giant dude with the giant adam's apple
and wearing the tight little women's
swim trunks where you can see all of
her body parts
she is totally a woman right and and we
all knew that that wasn't true and it
was so obvious
but
at least they were trying to have some
kind of coherent argument now
they don't do that will thomas basically
will just say and the people around him
will say yeah he's got an advantage well
too bad will thomas was asked about this
very problem and he didn't even address
the argument he didn't even really try
to make sense of it he's just said look
this is what i want and so i'm going to
do it
there are some who look at the data and
suggest that you're enjoying a
competitive advantage what do you say to
that there's a lot of factors that go
into
a race and how
how well you do and the biggest change
for me is that i'm happy
and sophomore year
where i had my best times competing with
the men i was miserable and so having
that
be lifted is incredibly relieving and
allows me to put my all into
training into racing trans people don't
transition for athletics we transition
to be happy and authentic
and our true selves
uh look i'm happy
oh what about the girls who don't want
me to strip naked in their locker rooms
well who cares what they think they're
somebody else they're not me and this is
what i want
oh oh you're asking me about the girls
whose trophies i'm taking away and whose
championships i'm taking potentially who
scholarships i'm taking yeah there are
other people i don't care about them i
care about me me me me me i'm happy
this is my authentic self now obviously
it's not his authentic self he is
authentically a man and he is deluded
and thinks that he's a woman and now our
society which has lost the threat even
more than this guy has
is encouraging him to say that he's he's
a woman he's not authentically a woman
ultimately it's not going to make him
happy these lies don't make anybody
happy not in the long term
but but he's not he's not even
addressing the question of truth and
falsehood the question of reality he
doesn't care
he is just locked entirely in his own
will in his own irrational desires
with all the pollen in the air in
nashville it sort of sounds like i am
transitioning right now that's what it's
gonna sound like for a lot of people
with him he doesn't even sound like he's
on any particular drugs he's got a
deeper voice than i do right now and he
says look last year when i was competing
with the men's team and i wasn't winning
the races i was sad and now i'm
competing on the girls team and i'm
beating all of them because i'm a
hulking giant dude and i'm happy so why
are why are you asking me about all this
nonsense about how boys have an
advantage over girls and biology and
reality how dare you how dare you talk
about my happiness and the happiness of
others who gives a damn
that's that's much scarier
when people are making bad arguments
that is preferable to people not making
arguments at all
because not making arguments at all just
reduces politics to grunting and
irrational sounds and brute force and
interest and increasingly that's what
our politics looks like
and there is a catering toward this
extremely small
sexual minority the san francisco mayor
london breed
has just announced
her plan to tackle the homeless problem
there's a huge homeless problem in san
francisco that city has collapsed in
recent years there's crime everywhere
you want to talk about needles and
addiction there's needles all over the
streets human feces all over the streets
the city is looking really really bad
but london breed is not going to be
addressing homelessness writ large she's
not going to be spending money to tackle
the homelessness problem
she's spending money to tackle
transgender homelessness she says today
i announced my five-year plan to end
transgender homelessness in san
francisco which includes investing in
programs to support
and create real long-term change in the
lives of transgender people she's going
to be spending six and a half million
dollars to do this
why why
why are all of the resources going
toward an extremely small number of
sexual deviants why it's it's not that i
don't have sympathy for these people
it's not that i don't want to help these
people but why are they the only people
that we're helping how about homeless
veterans don't you think maybe homeless
veterans
deserve a little bit of our taxpayer
money don't you think they deserve a
little bit of our attention
this is going to be shocking to say
don't you think they might even deserve
a little more of our attention than
people who you are defining simply by
their perverse sexual identities and and
desires and self-conception
don't you think maybe
if you went out and you served our
country and you put your life on the
line to defend our freedom don't you
think maybe you deserve a little of our
consideration no
how about the homeless elderly
senior citizens don't they deserve any
of our consideration no only an
extremely small minority of
men who think that they're women usually
and an even smaller minority of women
who think that they're men whose
delusions we are encouraging they get
all the attention they get all the money
they get all the focus
to the exclusion of everyone else it's
it's a hierarchy and part of the reason
that this is happening is because the
left understands incentives and they
like this they are promoting sexual
confusion they are they are discouraging
a politics based on reason based on
purpose based on traditionally
understood conceptions of the good and
what's right and what's true and what
leads to a flourishing society and
they're encouraging people to to pursue
one moral maxim above all others namely
if it feels good do it this is why
kirk cameron
the actor who's an outspoken christian
just came out he got in a lot of trouble
yesterday he was trending all over
social media because he was encouraging
homeschooling and he said
public schools are not merely neutral
public schools are not merely ignoring
what is good and true and beautiful but
they're actively undermining all of it
they don't want to abandon their
children to a system that by and large
is doing more grooming
for leftist politics
and sexual chaos
and racial confusion then they are doing
any real educating about truth beauty
and goodness
100
totally right
how could you send your kid to these
schools today
the public schools a lot of private
schools for goodness sakes even some of
the christian schools are encouraging
this stuff
the point of education is to is to
educate you it's to train you
it's to cultivate all those best things
in you
it's too as kirk points out
pursue the good the true and the
beautiful so if all the schools are
doing is grooming leftist politics and
sexual chaos
how could you send your kids there by
the way the wealthy the elite they're
probably not sending their kids there
they're they're probably sending their
kids to a
more ordinary at least relatively more
ordinary serious school that might in
some way educate them but for all the
rest of you hoy palloy out there no
spend your days watching drag queen
story hour because that's good for our
political agenda so says the left i'm so
glad you like that clip now you know
what you got to do you got to smash and
ring and bang and boom and zip and hit
the bell and do the subscribe so that
you can get notifications when all of my
videos come out you can also go to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
leave a 75 000 star review we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]